hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde wisst ihr dass ich seit über 11
Jahren Minecraft spiele und das auch
hier auf Youtube hochladen ich liebe
dieses Spiel über alles ich finde das
ist das beste Spiel was je entwickelt
wurde und von da interessiert mich
natürlich umso mehr was montanablack in
seinem ersten Minecraft Videos so
angestellt hat kostet das Geld das Spiel
[Musik]
war gut berechtigte Frage weil
mittlerweile ja Fortnite und sowas alles
kostenlos ist
was ist das wie kann ich denn sprinten
ja okay
das spiel halt in der beschissensten
Grafik spielt die es gibt ohne Shader
und sogar noch mit diesen komischen
schwarzen Streifen wo man Bildschirmrand
gefunden
oha der Profi Digger
der
hey ich weiß dass ich bei Minecraft mit
Luca Staffel 1 bei mir wo ich ja ein
Jahr am Stück nur Minecraft hochgeladen
habe das mit der auch unfassbar viele
Leute immer Ansagen gezogen haben und
meinten hey du hast ja 3 Minecraft
gespielt man sieht das voll guck mal das
ist doch dies das ist aber das ist unser
aber Monte hat er glaube ich noch nie
Minecraft gespielt
was besonderes
[Musik]
mit einer Blumen Stein abbauen
vielleicht ich glaube der Montana Black
ist so primär bekannt geworden durch
Fortnite oder und da ist es natürlich so
dass diese Pflanzen dir ja auch
Regenerationen geben die geben dir
glaube ich so ein Schild oder irgendwie
so von da ich kann seine Gedanken gegen
so leicht nachvollziehen noch
okay cool geil nein
er müsste sich halt einfach mal ein
bisschen mit dem Spiel auseinandersetzen
um zu wissen dass Minecraft daraus
besteht dass man ohne alles startet und
sich immer weiter hocharbeitet
was ist das hier
oh nein leben
erst mal ein bisschen Farbe da meine ich
verkehrt dicker guck mal wieso hat er
denn schon so jetzt eine goldhose und
zwar ob sie aktuell das war
wahrscheinlich in der in der Kiste von
diesem vorgebauten Portal da wo ist mein
Fisch
[Musik]
bitte pack ihn zumindest in den Ofen
bevor du isst Bruder
[Musik]
nicht so hinterher aber frisst das nicht
man
[Musik]
ey no joke ich verstehe es komplett es
ergibt der Sinn wenn man mit Inventar
ist dass man irgendwas essen will dass
man es auf den Charakteren zieht aber in
Minecraft packst du halt ins Inventar
und jetzt rechts links gedrückt also man
hätte sich ein bisschen vorher damit
auseinandersetzen können
und jetzt Rechtsklick AMK
was für Rechtsklick ah
aha aha wieso ist denn das Dunkel Digger
oh mein Gott jetzt kommen Monster ey ich
kacke meinen Arsch Digger das ist ja so
witzig
hä
der Klo Putz ach das ist sein Name ich
dachte
online irgendwo
mit dem Hühnchen
voll
du brauchst nicht mehr gerade ich ziehe
mir das kurz aus dem Arsch aus so
also no joke minecraft ist eigentlich
wirklich das einfachste Spiel der Welt
ne ja du gehst dann Inventar mit eh und
da machst du aus jemanden
vier Brettern machst du eine Werkbank
also wir Bretter in dieses Ding nicht
nicht Holzknopf ja du legst in jedes von
diesen vier Kästchen ein Brett kannst
einfach rechtsklick gedrückt halten und
einfach die so drüber ziehen dann geht
es erinnert mich gerade noch frontan ne
ich habe ja mal vor keine Ahnung wie
lange Zeit immer einen auf Senioren
zocken reagiert wie die zum ersten Mal
Minecraft gespielt haben das exakt das
gleiche die haben sich genauso hohl
angestellt du willst die ausmacht
Rechtsklick und platziert sie auf dem
Boden genau dann machst du Rechtsklick
auf die drauf und bist dann in der
Werkbank genau und da drin hast du jetzt
ganz viele verschiedene Rezepte
feuerzeugbogen
die sind ja alle rot eingekreist
ey es ist so
interessant das zu sehen
aber es ist auch
sehr frustrierend das zu sehen sondern
ich nehme hier gerade auf ach so warum
hast du mich denn angerufen sondern ich
habe dich vor zwei Stunden angerufen ich
bin ich werde nicht sterben auf dem Weg
zu dir da perfekt mir ist ein bisschen
zu stressig geschnitten für Minecraft
was ist dann die Missionen in Minecraft
sich eher was zu bauen das ist ein
sandblock Spiel so ne das heißt du
kannst halt einfach bauen was du
möchtest so es gibt viele verschiedene
Blöcke und Materialien mit denen du halt
Sachen bauen kannst ganz kurze
Zwischenfrage
ihr wisst ja ich kenne mich überhaupt
nicht aus in der ganzen
livestreaming-szene ich habe glaube ich
noch nie ein Twitch Livestream überhaupt
gemacht und bin auch absolut gar nicht
auf dieser Plattform unterwegs das
einzige was ich allerdings so natürlich
mitbekommen habe ist das montanablack zu
der berühmteste der meist abonnierte
Twitch Stream an Deutschland es kann
auch sein dass es nicht mehr ist aber
das ist so das was ich von Montana black
weiß
und dass die schauen sich dann so viele
Leute an
also sei ihm gegönnt ist überhaupt kein
Front aber
er ist ja am Pizza essen und einer
erklärt ihm dass es ein sandblock Spiele
ist es nicht mehr das ist Sandbox heißt
es glaube ich
das ist schon lachkick
das bin ich für euch da gibt's aber
bessere so nehmt ihr mich was wo ist
leider Wiedererkennungswert so seht ihr
mich sexy rish girl was ist das
du kannst das Spiel auch in Vollbild
machen mit F11 ne
aber man hat unten diese schwarzen
Ränder weil
das sieht auch so ein hässlich aus bei
ihm das Minecraft Ding wir müssen uns
erstmal den Punkt mehr merken falls ich
dann noch mal sterbe wie ihr meine Lava
guck mal das finde ich ist ein schönes
Fleckchen Erde so jetzt
wunderschöne Stück
er hat gar kein Holz er hat du hast doch
kein Holz oder
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ist einfach wirklich Senioren zocken ne
da haben wir eichelstamm rüber
genau du kannst auch shift drücken und
dann das anklicken dann wird er gleich
alles rausgezogen
ab wir die so nebeneinander legt um
wirklich ÜBERHAUPT keinen Platz zu
sparen ja du kannst doch Blöcke
platzieren ne ja du kannst einfach eine
Erde aus dem Stein drauf
er sich auch einfach jetzt straight
runterbauen
so weh im Herzen ihr wisst ja dass ich
nicht in Minecraft Schüler bin der sagt
boah ich mach Pio wie oft komplett und
lauf da rum und mache auf das Speedrun
Blabla sondern schön Shader rein Zeit
lassen ich würde auch niemals so was
abbauen weil mir das einfach das tut mir
im Herzen weh weil das ja überhaupt
nicht jetzt ist ey ich leide hier gerade
komplett wie ich mir dieses Video
angucke und äh wie viel Steine zwei
genau also eins in jedes Kästchen
darüber warum
[Musik]
aber woher soll man das dann alles
Wissen egal ja Bro das ist das also es
ist ja bei jedem Spiel so dass wenn man
das neue spielt man erstmal lost ist ich
finde aber das Minecraft im Gegensatz zu
beispielsweise Fortnite GTA FIFA oder
anderen Hype spielen die ja so weiß
nicht in den letzten Jahren an enormer
bekannter dazu gewonnen haben und jetzt
mittlerweile jeder kennt und jeder
spielt finde ich das Minecraft einem als
Anfänger schon eine Menge mit in die
Wiege gelegt beim Start also besonders
hiermit was man sich als als Anfänger
halt einschalten kann dass man alles
erklärt bekommt wie man sich irgendwas
craftet und es ist ja auch alles
ziemlich selbst erklärend logischerweise
kann man einen Baum schneller abbauen
wenn man Angst hat logischerweise kannst
du Erde oder sanche abbauen wenn du eine
Schaufel hast und Tiere oder Monster
schneller töten wenn du ein Schwert hast
das ist das ergibt ja auch alles Sinn
eigentlich
ja
er tötet jetzt ein Schaf mit einer
Spitzhacke so richtig jetzt passt in den
Bettchen und welchen Bau das Bett
alleine und ich zeig dir wie okay
Werkbank hier haben wir das schwarze
Bett wieso steht da schwarzes hä weil du
keine Bretter hast normales Holz
zerstämme du hast keine Bretter aber du
hast keine Bretter machen
erstmal alleine
[Musik]
es ist überhaupt kein Front ne es ist
wirklich überhaupt nicht böse gemeint
ich finde es extrem süß mir das hier
anzugucken und es ist wahrscheinlich
genau das gleiche wie werden Montana
black mir bei meinem ersten Mal Fortnite
zu sehen würde oder so halt Dinge die er
gut kann die ich nicht gut kann oder
zuerst war dann ausprobiere aber es tut
mir wirklich mehr zu mir sowas zu sehen
sorry also sorry allerdings würde ich an
der Stelle das heutige Video jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben Freunde wenn euch
meine Reaktion auf montes erstes Mal
Minecraft gefallen hat dann lasst gerne
einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen ich jetzt fünf Mal beten aber
ganz schnell